Big Brother Biden is back with a
vengeance the censorship happy crew over
at the White House aren't too thrilled
with Twitter's new owner Elon Musk you
see they're used to colluding with big
Tech in order to censor Americans and
whatever they deem misinformation but
the world's richest man actually sticks
to his Free Speech principles so the
White House has this warning
this is something that we're certainly
keeping an eye on and look
we you know we have always been very
clear
and that when it comes to social media
platforms it is their responsibility to
make sure that when it comes to
misinformation when we when it comes to
the hate that we're seeing that they
they take action that they continue to
take action again we're all keeping a
close eye on this but here's why the
White House is so worried Elon Musk says
he's preparing to release sensitive
Twitter files on Free Speech suppression
musk calling the threat from Biden's
goons messed up and also tweeting this
this is a battle for the future of
civilization if free speech is lost even
in America tyranny is all that lies
ahead and top Republican leader Kevin
McCarthy thinks elon's critics need to
back off
that is offensive to me government's
going to go after someone who wants to
have free speech
what do they have to look at Twitter
about
do they want to go more after American
public about whether they can have an
opinion on something
I think the American public have spoken
on this I think our first amendment
stands up and I I think they should stop
picking on Elon Musk
okay Dana you know we're keeping a close
eye on Twitter uh does it get any more
Big Brother than that I was actually I
wrote down that the white house needs to
take a step back because we know one
thing for sure they keep a very close
eye on Twitter they make all of their
policies based on what they see on
Twitter and they react to Twitter
constantly and you have the chief of
staff retweeting every little thing on
Twitter so that is like that is their
issue but
um
there is another thing that happened
today so Elon Musk announces this that
there's possibly going to be uh
transparency on what happened on the
censorship on the same time today Google
and YouTube announced this new fact
checking Global operation they're going
to have 13 million dollars for a new
Point partnership with pointer
institute's National fact checking
Network to promote more accurate
information online
now maybe it's going to be great I but I
I have a feeling that you will have a
lot of conservative sites say well wait
we can't even get on Google search
results so some everybody is afraid that
something else is happening on the other
side so I do think more transparency is
great if that's going to end gender
trust and more free speech that's really
good the White House I don't think they
need to be keeping a close eye on it
because that's actually the problem in
the first place that's why we have that
one issue on covid where you have the
white house now some of the former
employees having to give testimony about
whether they were talking to the big
tech companies to have them censor
things online about covid so it's coming
back to bite them
you know Greg this is anything get more
fascist than the termination of free
speech no I could think of some things
but that's for another time I want to
comment on what you just said they
pension they pay attention to Twitter so
much that they're taking it so hard
because they fear that they're going to
lose their crutch to twit their news and
their opinions are created by Twitter
Trends which are kind of created by a
loud minority of time wasting shut-ins
and that dictates their opinions right
and if you didn't like me if you didn't
like to think Twitter would do that for
you and now what you're seeing is all of
those unoriginal thoughts may go away
and where are they going to right you're
noticing if you if you're on Twitter you
notice that it's a lot more fun lately
and it seems like the angriest people
have migrated to Mastodon which is the
left-wing version of Twitter and they
are now censoring each other they're
banning each other so they took their
they took their own weird practices with
them and what's left on on Twitter is
kind of a more freeing and yes maybe
there might be something there that is
disagreeable but that's you know that's
part of speech and I think this is my
last point the reason why I think the
government and the media don't like
somebody who's waiting widening the
lanes of free speech is because they
defined disagreeableness as hate speech
and hate speech as crime therefore
disagreeable speech when it's on Twitter
makes Free Speech a crime so right free
speech allows for disagreeable speech
and you call that hate speech then
freedom of speech is in danger of being
called hate speech we talked about this
for years we said this is where it was
going
you know uh Bezos is is threatening
apple is threatening to block Twitter
from the App Store what's that all about
so Apple won't do business with Twitter
but they'll do business with the
Communist Chinese that tells you a lot
about Apple
I've noticed a little difference in
Twitter I've noticed there's less
disinformation there's less hate and
there's less liberals on Twitter I
wonder if that's a coincidence I do
agree with the White House on two things
one is you can't allow foreign bot
armies to come in and fight information
Warfare against the United States it's a
national security risk musk has that
under control but the government Can't
Ban American free speech in the name of
fighting foreign information and that's
tyrannical and also if I was running
Twitter I wouldn't want lots of people
saying kill whites kill cops kill blacks
you don't want that on your private
platform so you got to suppress that
kind of speech but
to use an analogy based off the World
Cup the White House is kind of like a
soccer player that flops
you say one critical thing oh you're oh
they're twisting and writhing they're
you're saying you're putting my life in
danger
this is a death threat no I just barely
tickled you and that's what they're
trying to do with hate speech anything
criticism hate speech um we're all gonna
die now what they're trying to do with
muscle they're trying to make them toxic
and they're trying to launch boycotts
against them but he has the more High
Ground because free speech is above all
that and he's winning the pr War because
he's funny
and that's as great as asset is he's
ridiculing the establishment and they
look sensitive and square and he's
enjoying himself in that fight and
that's what people see and it's
endearing you know Jessica Twitter is a
private company where does the
government get off saying we're going to
monitor this and we're gonna watch it
and just from a criminal justice
perspective you investigate crimes you
don't investigate people and companies
what is the crime so far well I that's
why we're only keeping an eye on the
situation but there is a long history of
tech companies working with the
government to make sure that dangerous
things don't happen and that's really
important and the covid-19
misinformation policy started under the
Trump Administration it was in early
2020 when there was tons of bad
information floating around and Trump
officials worked with Twitter and then
Biden took over and then Biden officials
worked with Twitter the same thing goes
on with YouTube works with Twitter he's
not a trump official he's been there for
80 000 years okay but he's whatever
everyone knows that fauci served in
eight administrations and one of them
was Donald Trump's and one of them is
Joe bidens and he also worked for all
the guys that came before him so let's
be clear about that
um when you say that Elon Musk is
winning the pr battle
at the rate that he's losing advertisers
he's not winning anything he still needs
to be profitable that was his goal right
in taking over this he thought he could
make it better and he thought that he
could make it produce more money and the
advertising model is always a challenge
when you're dealing with users
subscribers or viewers that's true but
he's getting way more users than he's
ever had
sure but okay yeah and so you go for a
pay model you know that's what a lot of
successful companies do Jessica
you know stay after stay after class
we're going to talk about the economics
of Twitter
I can't wait but I have to be somewhere
um the whole Mastodon thing I find
incredibly funny like all these people
that I follow posting you know it's if
it becomes unsafe for us here this is
where you can find me yeah it's not that
serious Twitter is the only social media
that I have I really enjoy it like if
I'm doom scrolling I'm doing it on
Twitter and if it went away in about a
week we would all be okay right it its
main function is to get you up-to-date
news information at least for people who
work in the business that we do and
majority of the people that we're
interacting with one place drudge
basically right before Twitter you were
always looking to Drudge and now you
just now it's refresh I think yeah not
so much for my people but yeah if people
were looking for my people but are you
hanging out with Kanye again not even I
would like to talk talk about that so
if it'll be interesting to see when all
of these people who have been banned I
know Kanye was only suspended for a
couple weeks because of his anti-semitic
tweet but it will be interesting to see
how far musk will go in terms of
restoring accounts to people who are
really Republican repugnant and I'm sure
he won't bring on you know bring back
Nick Fuentes and Alex Jones but that
will be repugnant versus another
standardizers are just straight up hate
speech is protected by
and the Constitution and the United
States Supreme Court okay it just
blanked hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else